salut aujourd'hui je vous emmène au
sénat alors est-ce que je mentalise et
des politiques je ne sais pas ce qui est
drôle c'est que juste à côté du sénat on
veut lire ça
je me demandais si j'étais arrivé à
destination mais apparemment non vous je
marche encore un peu sur le perron du
sénat sais pas qui je vais rencontrer de
hauts de gamme
maintenant on est dans les bureaux du
sénat mais on n'a pas trop le droit de
filmer au sénat en fait on doit pas
fumer quelque chose qui montre qu'on est
au sénat cette fois on est dans un petit
hôtel formule 1 on a mis un ordinateur
une imprimante pour faire genre mais j'y
suis vraiment et je suis allé il dit au
téléphone
il est un boulot sérieux non je peux pas
trop vous dire si du bourg attention
apparition tout le monde se dit mais
c'est qui en fait elle vous présente
antoine buéno elle a entendu bruno andré
vous le connaissez pas ce qu'il joue
actuellement au point manuelle dans son
spectacle
combien de guano oui antoine bueno
l'espoir c'est le titre total du
spectacle tous les seuils de
désintoxiquer de vous désintoxiquer de
votre espoir et c'est la joie de vivre
elle est de la pure en cette période
ça se voit en même temps il travaille au
sénat ouais il fait quoi exactement
je m'occupais du affaires culturelles et
du développement durable voilà et tu
vois là on voit qu'on touche à la
politique c'est ce qu'on n'a rien
compris les affaires culturelles et du
développement durable
pas pourquoi la comprenne que
globalement quand il ya des trucs qui se
passent au sénat sur la pulsion
développement durable le clin d'oeil je
suis en fait je suis pas persuadé que
les gens sachent ce prénom sipa société
à ben alors très sincèrement c'est à peu
près ce qui se passe à leur santé
nationale
je vous en fais rire tu lui donnes à
trois derrière l'écran qu'on fait à la
réunion s'en fait c'est à dire oui par
énormément de choses mais tout l'hérault
mais on examine tout dès lors je n'ai
pas dit qu'on les modifier vous mais on
les examine et dans les votes
voilà son boyau plus je lui ai demandé
de me rapporter anecdote un truc que tu
as pas forcément raconte à tout le monde
c'est parce que je peux pas savoir où
elle quelque chose de bien c'est sûr
c'est vraiment dans la dentelle a déjà
là oui parce que ça fait un peu
un quart d'heure plus tard dit sa maman
je mange plutôt rigolote
or explique marc ans en tout cas le
jeune homme je sais pas mais parce que
moi qui m'amuse en désespérant un peu
voilà tout autant tu as des mots clés en
tête qu'il peut briller chrysler cette
année
est ce qu'un danger dans le tas un objet
ouais ça dépend ce qu'on appelle un
objet quelque chose qu'on peut tenir
qu'on peut tenir le toucher tbc man ray
hé ouais c'est que maintenant vraiment
un super bluffé territoire écoute moi je
fais un petit patch work
d'après moi correspondent à frédéric
dolt mais alors je le cache table pour
le moment pour réussir puisqu'il y avoir
voici ma prédiction antoine renaud qui
j'espère fera en partie à des éléments
de soirée les tops que tu vas lui
raconter que je ne connais pas forcément
passé avec d'autres puisque tu ne parles
pas sûr parce que s'il y en a bien un
qui voudra jamais m'aider à dormir
maintenant puisque moi ajouté ce soit
l'employeur alors c'est une chose que
j'ai que j'ai apprise en m'occupant
d'une loi qui est passé au sénat remet
très récemment cette marianne c'est la
loi relative à la biodiversité d'accord
alors il y avait un article de cette loi
qui interdisait une forme de chasse que
les gens connaissent pas forcément qui
s'appelle la chasse à la glu à la lune
inclus oui c'est à dire
la plus petite et la plus con colle
absolument c'est à dire que ça consiste
à mettre de la glu sur des arbres et il
ya des oiseaux qui viennent s'y coller
et guy simplice et mon cerveau je vais
partir tout à fait qui l'autorisé dans
un certain nombre de départements qui
est une pratique historique en fait qui
correspond à des traditions il donc ce
qu'on appelle la chasse avec lui les
oiseaux fait pas depuis des années donc
ça veut dire que chaque série est une
série b moyens je me dis pas
émotionnelle de coller les autocars et
dans les causes en question c'est pas
eux qu'on chasse les oiseaux deviennent
d un peu long des appelants sont les
oiseaux sont en revanche assez et alors
donc le juge est ce qu'on veut la tuer
nos femmes ans après un titre personnel
on sait absolument abominable abjecte
barbares signal
et donc il se trouve que le sénat a
supprimé l'article qui interdisait cette
forme de chasse d eau qu ensuite un
débat là-dessus et finalement l'article
n'a jamais été rétablie car pas encore
été rétablie s'il veut un jour et je
pense pas qu'il ne sera donc la chasse
avec lieu dans la loi dans le bio
diversité continue d'être autorisée et
dans l'autre anecdote un petit peu dans
la
autre anecdote un petit peu dans le même
esprit mais dans le sens inverse c'est
que il y avait un certain nombre de
sénateurs des colonies qui ont déposé un
amendement pour que les poteaux certains
poteaux qui sont mis en place par les
opérateurs de réseaux téléphoniques
peuvent accéder les antennes relais donc
il ya des poteaux et ses poteaux au
sommet ne sont pas facturés
ils ne sont pas fermées je ne savais pas
le résultat de ça c'est que les oiseaux
beaucoup d'entre eux tombent dedans
ah oui d'accord voilà ils sont moins les
prix moyens sont calculés croire un
refuge dominante dans la plaine saint
flour sortir et donc ils sont
littéralement figé dedans a dit pour un
certain nombre des ses poteaux on trouve
jusqu'à un mètre cinquante de cadavres
d'oiseaux et donc il ya eu un amendement
déposé au sénat pour obliger les
opérateurs à obturer a fermé ses poteaux
et cet amendement n'a pas été adopté
donc effectivement c'est très drôle hein
mais sa frappe quand même passé moi
c'est quelque chose auquel je pense
depuis j'ai fait ça parce que ça mode de
vie relativement et alors il ya une
forme d'humour noir effectivement à
imaginer la barbarie et d'atrocités dont
vous pouvez être les auteurs qu'est-ce
qu'on pouvait pas mettre un petit peu
plus en haut du poteau
oui pour le faire mais avec un point par
exemple mais ça c'est l'aspect très
pratique un du mentalist il ya une
antenne bricolage 1 mondial cet escompte
bricolage dans toute chose que tu fais
bien de dire c'est surtout le mentaliste
qui dit ah là là je suis pas tout à fait
sérieux autant il ya un élément de sa
qui correspond à des anecdotes dans les
deuxième ch peuvent dès maintenant je
pense savoir pourquoi par exemple nous
avons rien de bon
je leur ouvre un cabinet et à
l'intérieur ça parle de travail l'autre
c'est ça parlait de buch l'occurrence
michel ça j'ai eu ensuite je pensais
qu'avec parler de quelque chose en
rapport avec les pendaisons parce que
j'avais l'image d'une potence ah oui je
pense qu elle fait d'avoir une image
d'un poteau est tout à fait ça m'agace
un petit peu mais pourtant il est quand
même très famille excuse moi mais eux
plus les potences c'est un ce
extraordinaire c'est vrai tu devrais en
faire un métier que j'ai choisi anger
hossein rassam et sinon ça c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est vraiment les mettre à
la potence et tous et du coup j'étais
très curieux d'ailleurs deux jours c'est
que ces principautés but fois que les
gens écoutent gelé mais non il ya du
choix il ya plus de choix pour vous ne
croyez vous vous arrêtiez à dire dans
les commentaires des vidéos il ya trop
de couples se sont et complice et moi on
a créé cette identité au point les gens
qui me connaissent
le savent je ne souhaite vraiment le
bien et le succès de personnes va donc
gérer ge avait aucune raison d'arrêter
ceux qui ont un travail alors forcément
glu ça c'est pas mal plus assez plein et
il est beau tout neuf ans au togo dans
ces secteurs
merci lundi une vidéo avec bonheur
il ya 14 ans dans sa tête il match qui
est depuis lundi fait merci à toi
antoine vous pourrez retrouver je vous
en donne bruno dans son spectacle au
premier venu dans ce moment pauvres
vivent tous les mercredis à 19h
activement le point virgule par ailleurs
plutôt le sport et vous avez dans le
descriptif de la vidéo toutes les infos
sur pas de quoi le rajouter sur facebook
chat facebook je vais sauter parole
c'est la meilleure des points du monde
je l'envoie que s'ils sortaient ce vrai
je pars demain 17h - le prochain bal
blog châu